quella senti ragazzi mi chiami stanno
strozzando ottima la partenza ben
ritorno a casa quelli aggiunti ragazzi e
benvenute non ci credo ecco [ __ ]
pensa a tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo il nuovo
blog prima di cui c'è ragazzi cosa al
solito di partire con la frenata della
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da chiara che ha fatto allora
ragazzi questa è la foto
questa è la fanale di come è possibile
questa cosa c'è è una figata pazzesca
merita di vincere la frana ma
soprattutto per l'originalità del fatto
che ha fatto bene anche questo muro
questo qui quindi meritava di vincere
tutto questo ragazzi devi passare alle
news la prima news che voglio darvi e
non è una news un ringraziamento e per
essere arrivati a un milione e 700 mila
iscritti dio mio dio mio non so più cosa
dire io ormai tanto ormai tanto si dice
no non si dice però va beh chi se ne
fottono c'è c'è e ringrazio nei cinque
minuti per qualcosa ma è così cazzo è
così siete meravigliosi
continuerò a fare buttato giù questo
mentre facevo così continuerò a fare il
pirla appunto stavo dicendo questo non
crea se non si fosse notato sono tornato
nella mia incredibile dimora e mi sembra
assurdo perché dopo aver passato la vita
tra gli scarafaggi
brutti ricordi solo che domani che
sarebbe oggi per voi che uscito il video
sarò già los angeles e ci sarò per
cinque giorni più o meno dove farò un
blog di quelli epici che riassume tutta
los angeles preparate i ragazzi per la
bomba assoluta ed è dovesse ragazzi
prima di passare a fare risponde devo
farvi vedere una cosa che mi allora ogni
tanto mi ricordo chi me l'ha chiesto ma
ogni tanto mi chiedete farvi vedere che
cosa fai prima di registrare un video
c'è proprio quei minuti prima di
iniziare a registrare un mio video che
cosa succede in quelle tre minuti prima
c'è un video che era appunto tra quelli
che ho fatto in marocco dove ho
registrato anche il prezzo prima perché
stava scaricando il gioco questo è
quello che faccio prima di registrare i
miei gameplay
buona visione a tutti ragazzi e poveri
dove sono video sono fa vj che ci siamo
sudditi quali 2015 simulator noti parti
simulator 2015 io leggo e contrari
mancano 2 minuti e 56 secondi per finire
di scaricarlo porca la [ __ ] e
vogliono le foto mie belle rosse che
bella che bella forza mi conveniva
partire da dopo quella che bella faccia
che ciò che è bello che sanità torni mi
stupisco di questa bellezza sconfinata
che ho incredibilmente nelle foto se mai
mi son cagato addosso
ragazzi siamo partiti non minuto alla
fatica guardare le foto che bello bravo
bravo bel montaggio non ci non si vede
che non c'è il braccio qua dietro
complimenti favi sai usare photoshop o
mio dio sembra mia madre quando le dico
che ho preso 4 più o meno uguale
partiamo questo cazzo di t simulator un
minuto ragazzo dimise uno deve aspettare
per fare del cazzo di te ditemelo
contornato ormai dal marocco ma sto
video l'ho fatto mentre ero in marocco
quindi mancano trenta secondi per
scaricare dei 7 mega se un beduino
andasse a prendere il kappa boys e me li
portasse sul computer sarebbe più
semplice per ok ma che bello sonno
quando faccio queste cose ma questo
ragazzini che possiamo partire col fare
risponde la prima domanda non poteva che
essere questa ma doveva far vedere lui
che si tuffava in piscina quei vestiti
siccome non avevo messo sta roba
nell'ultimo l'odine è tempestato di
domande tipo fa rima perché non metti
marchiatura ok ok
[Applauso]
[Risate]
c'è allora sentite voi avete idea di
quanto cazzo ci mettono ad asciugare
queste scalo sapete quanto cazzo ci sono
ancora bagnate queste cose sono ancora
bagnate ed è per questo che non volevo
metterlo perché mi faceva girare un po
il pen dovesse essere che il nome di
merda sedurlo se dovrei una capra e anzi
questo è di fretta dell'odio scorso
sedurla e una capra quindi seduci te
stesso wow
il fallito tentativo di rating ma io non
sono una capra zio c'è guarda me sembra
una capra questa questo è un asino cazzo
capito adesso avrei cambiato il nome che
è brutto poi risponde perché lo fai una
chubby bagni un po diversa come speciale
qualche numero per questi ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fa vj ci
siamo sullo speciale qualche numero è
questa è scatola di marshmallow anche
bello che questo bambino come cazzo si
sa non si sa però non ce la farò mai ha
fatto già viva non si apre un cazzo ma
che cazzo non porca [ __ ] sigillato
sto coso
torna trovato bene sia aperto è una
chiave in bagno un po diversa ma è una
chubby barney soprattutto sul mio pene
mi è rimasto questo for one che schifo
sono durissimi come la cia ma chissà
quanti anni ci hanno sì marshmallow è
stato orribile molto quindi ragazzi
detto questione è che possiamo passare
alla famiglia mandela fari domanda di
oggi è come cazzo le asciugo le scarpe
come mi serve sapere questa cosa al più
presto perché sono così e non possa
andare in america così che sporca st
calza [ __ ] [ __ ] i ragazzi spero che
video vi sia piaciuto è come al solito
servizio è piaciuto lasciato momento mi
piace fatemi sapere per le scarpe che mi
serve anche la faccia di facebook e come
non i video trovata una descrizione sono
sempre si discuterà cimitero posso vita
e le ragazze